[Music]
here's a topical monologue I've been
watching I've been watching a lot of the
news lately uh and by that a lot I mean
uh one
episode yeah I watched an episode of the
news is that how you is that how
grown-ups talk did you see the
news I don't know what that was anyway I
noticed something interesting a lot of
people have you noticed this a lot of
people have you noticed a lot of people
just trying to make it feel make it feel
late nighty have you seen that a lot of
people out there in the news world are
uh revealing big secrets that's a big
thing there's like the Wikileaks guy
there's uh Edward Snowden everyone is
talking or squealing or leaking
something you know what I mean that was
that was not intentional and that was
horrible but it's true I didn't mean to
sound gross people people are are
leaking things things are being leaked
and I get it secrets secrets secrets you
guys secrets are fun and humans are the
only species on Earth that get to enjoy
them so enjoy them you'll never see a
lion
like I a
zebra I don't know how to do it with a
paw and I'm terrible at them I am
terrible at holding in a secret you tell
me a secret here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to do what everyone does I'm
going to assume I'm not the only person
you're telling sit on it for a few days
then let it out when you can't quite
trace the leak back to me that's what I
do and that's what everybody does people
who want you to keep their secrets are
asking too much they get all serious
like don't tell don't tell don't don't
don't py don't tell I'm serious serious
don't
tell what do I work for
you I'm going to let this baby out first
chance I get but I'll go through the
motions just to get that sweet sweet
dish I'll say whatever I need to say I'm
just like yeah yeah yeah I won't tell
anyone I promise I promise it's like the
iTunes agreement I'm just like yeah yeah
yeah blah blah blah blah Caron is
pregnant you know what I mean it's fun
make with the
dish